So once you've identified maybe a bunch
of people you want to interview and
maybe offer a job to.
Being compelling to them, why should
they come on board with you beyond
obviously just getting a paycheck,
can be a challenge in and of itself.
I personally have received many
recruiting emails that say, hey, we're
a hot new startup doing this thing,
that I really just don't care about.
So being able to infuse or fire up
people's passions about what they care
about is probably the most critical
element in the hiring process.
And having a way to engage the middle
level that would let them commit to you
and your business and
the growth of your business over time.
Doing that means being passionate about
what you say and why you're doing this,
and being honest, and
maybe a little vulnerable, too.
It's an uncomfortable place to be and
requires a lot of sort of emotional
intelligence on your behalf.